foreign
[Music]
submitting here at the ICC on Tuesday a
formal request to investigate and
prosecute those responsible along with a
dossier of evidence collected over the
past six months the submission to the
ICC prosecutor has highlighted the new
witness evidence and video footage which
clearly shows that Serena and her
colleagues were directly fired at by
Israeli Defense Forces there is ample
video footage of the vehicles that were
involved we have number plates
identified it will be possible to
identify the units involved those who
are in command at the very least those
in command should be held responsible
because they have said there is no
suspicion here of of any crime
so there's been a complete cover-up
[Music]
s
the evidence they say refutes the
Israeli claim that Shireen was caught
somehow in crossfire between Israeli
soldiers and Palestinian gunmen on the
scene in other words that her killing
was an accident the evidence say lawyers
leaves no doubt that there was no other
firing taking place that there were no
Palestinian gunmen in the vicinity
Sheeran's murder is the ultimate
demonstration of a pattern
IDF targeting journalists
this is called a war crime the evidence
is overwhelmingly clear it's time for
the ICC to take action and we would
expect anyone to do the same if it was
your sister your aunt or best friend
that was killed the media group was in
full view at all times of the Israeli
soldiers wearing brightly marked
Insignia identifying them as journalists
the Israeli claim therefore according to
this dossier of evidence that no crime
was committed has been sorely undermined